Yeah. There was a recent one. People are
saying that his son did it. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. My mother always believed that, but
again, sense of conspiracy theory though.
Right, and that's why I don't
really get into, yeah. Yeah. That's,
those are the ones that are out there.
I don't really get into that.
I don't come near the moon.
I don't go near a,
I'm not an Oj truther are you a a Gulf
of Tonkin guy or operation Northwoods?
Those were all true. There's
nothing, there's nothing.
Those are all true operation
Northwoods is my favorite. Crazy. Yeah.
They stay talked about bombing a ship.
Yeah.
With people on it and then we're going
to blow up a drone jetliner and blame it
on the Cubans. They were going to, they
were going to attack Guantanamo Bay arm,
Cuban friendlies and have them attack
Guantanamo Bay. Crazy. Yeah. Yeah.
That was not, that was not that long
ago. I know. That's why we need you back.
I can't do it. We know what
peer are too fucking exhausted.
I got exhausting because I would do a
show and then somebody would come up to me
after this show and they'd be like, they'd
show me a pizza menu. I swear to God,
Nigga, you see that? And I go, no, what
is it? They go, that's the nambla symbol.
And I'm like, it says it says
garlic knots. And they're like,
no. They're like, you had to really
look at it. Oh. And I'm like, all right,
I can't go with the rest
of my life with that.
Will they look for it and everything.
Everything's a conspiracy.
And then when it comes back to you and
they say, oh, Tim is involved in this,
and then you go, oh, I see how this
works. Yeah. Just make shit up. Yeah.
And then they believe it. You're the CIA
is now getting involved in podcasting?
Yes. Do you guys, you're
their first shelf,
but they're going to get a few others
on the deeply involved in steam.
Started the Russian trolls.
I lived at the of the CIA going
and watching sets and be like,
who's getting passed at the
store? Oh, you don't know.
I have a friend of mine who thinks that
the CIA started Jim Morrison and Jimi
Hendrix.
There's a book about that called Weird
scenes inside the canyon written by a guy
named Dave McCowen. Yes. I'm
going to tell you right now, Joe,
it's kind of interesting. I didn't
tell you. It's kind of interesting.
There was a lot of shit
going on in Laurel Canyon.
I'm sure it probably about pussy. There
was a lot of weird shit going on. The CIA,
the Rand Corp was all over there. There
was a lot of shit happening. Well,
I'm sure there was a
lot of shit happening,
but there is not a fucking intelligence
agency in the world that can create a
Jimi Hendrix of course, and they're not
sitting there. That book was like that.
They were managing the birds. The
CIA was like, they were like, no,
it's mister timber. Rattlers like a CIA
guy. Gotta be like, it's tambourine meds.
Imagine being in that time in the country
when everything was just falling apart
left and right around us,
Vietnam war, Kent State,
just fucking Nixon's the president
and it's just chaos left and right.
There's no internet. Yeah, everyone's
doing drugs. It must have been wild.
It must have been amazing.
I always think about that.
A hunter s Thompson quote
about, uh, you know,
like we talked about the 60s and that
in the 70s it was almost like the wave
crested and then just it's crashed act
from fear and loathing in Las pass. Yeah.
Yeah. But I'm a big,
like I'm a Kennedy Guy.
I think there's something really shady
with that. Yeah, for sure. For sure.
For sure. I mean, that book, there's some
amazing stuff. This book that you gave me,
his family of Seo Secrets, a guy, Russ
Baker, who's a legit journalist and it's,
it's been praised by like Dan
Rather and bill Moyers. Man,
I'm trying to get you in this. Let me
tell you right now. This will get you in.
We'll get you in. I don't have
that kind of time for George H.
Did you know the George Hw Bush called
the FBI and said that he thought he knew
who the killer of JFK was?
Did you know that? No. No.
He called the FBI. The in Houston. Hey,
what's up? It's George George Bush.
I'm in Tyler, Texas, and I
think I know who the killer is.
And he informed on this Guy James Parrot
and James Parrot ended up being like
one of his staffers.
It was this weird cover story.
He kind of planted and that came out
in a memo and there was another mental,
these are declassified FBI memos,
freedom of Information Act.
There was another memo that said after
the assassination, j Edgar Hoover brief,
George Bush and the CIA.
The problem was George Bush should not
have been working for the CIA at that
point. He should have been
just a private citizen.
So it was suggested he was working for
the agency for a very long time and he
was made the,
uh,
the director of the agency for one
year after the family jewels came out,
which was this whole thing with the CIA,
went to Congress and they admitted that
they had done all these things from,
you know,
coups and formenting revolutions and
countries and they made him the director
for one year after that happened to break
to make a clean break from all of the
nefarious activities that the
agency had been involved with.
But if you take that memo to mean that
he had had an existing relationship with
them, he was actually just
becoming the door. Cause not,
it made no sense to anyone.
They were like,
why is this guy that everyone called
the lightweight becoming the head of the
CIA after the CIA just admitted
to all these horrible things?
They call them a lightweight. Yeah,
they called. Yeah. He was like,
I think Kissinger and said to Nixon,
kissed her and said to Nixon like,
he's a lightweight, admit
him, ambassador to China.
He was never a guy that had a serious
political capital and he was made the head
of the CIA and then after that memo
was unearthed, people were saying, oh,
he had, this was an extension of
the coverup. He was being made,
the director at this very interesting
time in history because he actually had
worked with the agency forever and
he was not at all a lightweight.
He was a serious operator and he was
going in there to kind of clean up and
transition them into a new era. It's
a, I'm telling you, I'm already out.
You're done. How are you
out? I can't listen to that.
It's good. It's great though.
I need current shit. I ended up at
Denny's. I'm like, Julian Assan,
I need something. Right. I need some
Edward Snowden or done. All right.
You know to the bush and
I'll get an a sandbox.
You can get in there. I'll listen to,
I'm telling you in a clinic, if you read,
if you, I'll dabble in the clinic.
If you read a chapter of this,
if you read a chapter of this, I give
me a cookie. I don't have a cookie.
And if I do, I'm taking it.
But you will be, you'll be,
it's very interesting and it's a well
written book cause it's not reckless and
slop. I'll read the first
chapter, I promise. Thank you.
I will listen to a buddy
of mine gave me a David uh,
Lifton's best evidence on the Kennedy
assassination and that got me into
conspiracy theorists is like
92. And I get it. You're,
you're at the end of the
road now where you're like,
this is a lot of people are full of shit
in that world. A Lot, a lot of them.
And that's what people don't realize.
Well then it gets deeper and deeper and
deeper and more and more preposterous.
Have you ever googled Hashtag spaces fake?
No,
but that's sounds,
it sounds amazing.
There is a thriving
space is fake community.
Have you ever been in space? No.
Good point. It could be fake.
Come back. Come back to us. Joe. Prove
it. Now what is space? Come back to him.
Well,
this is an extension of flat earth.
It's like for people to think the flat
earthers stupid conservative. They go,
they go deeper. It's like it's not stupid.
They go deep. Those flat Earth Cox,
they want to move into space.
They want to go to spaces bank.
Yeah.
You want to know what's really up
spaces face basis. Fake. Yeah. Crazy.
What I mean I think there are hundreds
of thousands of people that think that
the earth is flat.
Hundreds of thousands educated Western uh,
American human beings that think
the earth is flat. That is wild.
It is fucking crazy.
It's interesting.
It's a lot of people that just
get educated from youtube.
The Guardian actually
had an article about it.
I sent it to Eddie and
Eddie's laughed at me.
See I think Eddie's kind of
rational and a lot of ways,
cause I met conspiracy talks with
him about what about well yeah, no,
the one that we had wasn't saying a
little government was attacking Malibu.
Well he's the one that
came up to me about,
we're talking about that they were using
direct energy weapons and I was like,
I dunno if this is Jackie Malibu,
but with what?
I was like why would they attack mallet,
whatever the fires. But I'm like,
they're rich. Why would they attack mal
boats to rich people? Fire started here.
My fucking house. They start a
mal, but they flew through the air.
You know I was one of the first
evacuated. Right. These fucking theories.
You're so stupid. It's dry
a shit. Yeah. A fire hits.
The winds are going co did they
make the wind picked? May Do.
I am sure always made the wind.
The wind is always been the CIA.
They've always made the wind. Yeah. It's
fucking, it's just any, there's no rest.
There's no peace.
There's no living in the moment.
Certain point you go to just don't
even want to know because it's horrible
things going on. There's
horrible things going on. Okay.
What do you think is like the worst shit
going on right now? Human trafficking's.
Very bad. Horrible, horrible
and really dollar industry.
That's not subway sandwich. Artists are
paying for that. Right? Rich people,
some of them are involved in
some very bad things and they're,
it's their track should be,
they're covering their own
tracks. Yeah. Like that.
Jeffrey Epstein that the Clinton visited
the least got an ice cream somewhere.
Anyone with an island and hanging
out with Bill Clinton. Yeah.
If you have an island and you're
hanging out with Bill Clinton,
there's a problem.
Where's the Mataz
crazy. All of that stuff is
very disturbing and he got
a sweetheart deal cause he
wouldn't inform on anyone that was on
his plane and now they're the justice
department is looking at that again.
It'll probably be fine.
They'll probably just let it, you know
with a guy like that, like what? You know,
how much does he know?
How does it stay alive because it's the,
he's not going to say anything.
Not going to talk.
I wouldn't trust him if
he files on that plane.
I think that's the other thing about see
the aversion of conspiracies as you go.
Like nobody would,
people would talk.
The reality is people wouldn't talk
if you were from a prominent family.
If it had been like a religion to stay
silent, if you had had CIA training,
if you would.
These people don't talk and we know that
there have been plots that have gone on
known for a very long time too in Iran.
So guy like Jeffrey Epstein
is so involved, so deep,
he knows he'll get killed.
He won't say anything. Yeah.
He's not going to say anything.
Plus he doesn't want to go to jail.
He doesn't want to go to jail and
he doesn't want to say anything.
Middle of the things that
he did. Yeah. So the, the,
the child thing is the creepiest of all,
it was gross and unfortunately it's,
it's a, it's a real thing. So what,
you know, people you could talk about,
there's the conspiratorial angles,
the bullshit,
but then there's the real
feathers. Sandusky, Sandusky,
like church hundred percent.
That's how the fire,
the people that are in love
with conspiracies never
care about private prisons
or the Catholic Church. And I'm like,
guys, this is not even debatable. Right?
We're not even debating. Right.
Private prisons are ruined.
Kids are being sold into slavery.
Ryan,
about how horrible the
judge in Pennsylvania,
crazy taking an underage kids
and just giving them sentences,
ridiculous sentences for shit.
That's crazy. Exchange for money.
That's not right and now
he's in jail. Yeah. It's uh,
there's some darkness in the world.
It's undeniable and when
something like San Dusky,
when that Penn state thing comes
out and you're like, wait a minute,
how long was this going on for and
how many people knew? Everyone knew.
How does everyone know? Yeah, it's
crazy. Turnover. Just he died quick,
but this is what I'm course
but doesn't mean he destroyed.
This is what I mean about people where
it's like youtube is gonna like central
conspiracy theory type stuff.
I'm like,
all of those things would have been called
conspiracy theories at one point. Yes.
Catholic church. Sandusky, blue grade,
and they said it was a few bad apples.
It was a labyrinth of torture. Prisons.
It was a program designed by the Pentagon.
CIA. It's crazy. What is
the youtube going to do?
They're going to censor recommending.
I think they just not recommending
conspiracy videos from what I've heard,
but I was reading that thing that
you were telling me about Jamie.
This whole like porn or child
porn or pedophile network,
you're setting account of what
is this, a pedophile, youtube,
what's going on in communication network.
They were communicating with each other
and youtube comments ever responded
yesterday and they said that they uh,
disabled comments on tens of millions
of videos and deleted a lot of accounts
that were, they were communicating in the
comment section of like a little kid's
cheerleading and whatnot.
How were they communicating to try to,
to share child porn or where
they are communicating to molest.
You don't know in the way pedophiles
communicate and their network, but
I'd like you to do a little bit more work.
Pull up an article on due
diligence on the pedophile.
I want you to go under the dark web
burner computer for the download Tor and
let's get moving.
We got to figure shit out.
You got to get a VPN or there that's the
FBI will take over child points had on
tour and then Ronnie for a year you
become the talk. Wait, what is that?
What's going on?
I imagine what they see to
see that that's a problem.
It is a problem because you're causing,
that happened that our Kelly Case,
there's a video of him doing something
with an underage girl and like I think
some people at CNN, it's like we've
seen it but and that's led to him going,
it's like, well what did you
watch? And is that legal?
Probably as legal cause you're watching
under the guise of of dining out
rough. Yeah. That kind of Shit is real.
And the fact that there's these
networks of people that are trying to,
you know, cultivate these
experiences. It's crazy man.
But if you're a rich person,
you have that sick predilection,
you're going to find a way to think of
what they're doing. Like uh, for example,
okay.
The poster remarks that praise the girls
ask whether they were wearing underwear
or simply carried a string of sexually
suggestive emojis. Bout two years ago,
hundreds of companies pulled money from
Youtube over concerns about ads showing
up next to problematic content from terror
or hate groups and videos is seem to
endanger exploit children.
I think, you know,
we've talked about this
before with youtube with the
issues that we've had with
them.
They,
they have way too much content
and way too few people.
There's no way they can watch all of it.
And when Shit like this where people
are doing things in the comments,
it's almost impossible to check.
Yeah.
I mean it's just the youtube comments
are one of the rare free range sort of
like unchecked message boards in the, in
the world. I'm sure I'll find out later.
Don't read it. Don't read it
Bro. Who is this fat fuck don't,
it's not even a black ballerina.
Why is he here? Who is that?
Don't read it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Um,
I wonder if there's ever going to
be a time where that is impossible,
where like these child pedophile rings,
they can figure out a way to snuff all
that out. I'm harder now than ever before.
I'm imagining. It's very
tough and it's tough, I think,
because so few people want to believe
that it's a problem in the way that it is,
because there's good people in the
world that don't think these things are
issues, right. So I think there's,
the political will isn't there
because people don't, aren't really,
they don't understand that it's,
you know,
and then the people that are doing
these things are very wealthy,
powerful people,
and they have a lot of control and
they can kind of cover their tracks.
If they're all wealthy on all of them.
For poor pedophile,
you're not going to a ring.
What are they doing? Some kid,
I know it's bad, but if you're rich,
pedophile, it's a nicer experience.
It's like you go on vacation versus me
going on vacation, you go on vacation.
It's a nice experience. I go on
vacation, you know, it's fine.
Sandals in The Bahamas.
No scandals where you go
on a cabin or something.